Das war die Sensation im Letzten Jahr: Harvard
Professor Alexander Loeb äußerte die These,
dass das Interstellare Objekt 1I Oumuamua
eine Aleinsonde oder der Rest einer Aliensonde
sein könnte.
Fakt war: das Objekt wurde so stark von Sonnenwinden
beschleunigt, dass das nur mit der Beschaffenheit
eines Sonnensegels erklärt werden konnte.
Sprich: Das Objekt musste extrem dünn und
leicht sein.
Bam.
Ein natürlicher Ursprung wäre damit sogar
unwahrscheinlich.
Und jetzt gibt es eine weitere Studie und
auch die sagt: Ja: es ist ein Sonnensegel!
Und wir wissen auch woher es kommt.
Und das es noch mehr davon gibt.
What?
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich willkommen!
Als ich vor mehr als fünfzehn Jahren mit
den Planungen von Clixoom anfing schlug mir
blankes Unverständnis entgegen.
Video im Internet?
Wie soll das denn gehen?
Die Rechner sind doch so langsam.
Und die Übertragungen im Netz, die sind doch
auch so langsam.
Ich: Aber das wird doch alles schneller!
Ja, aber und dann wurden immer weiter irgendwelche
Rahmenbedingungen der damaligen Zeit hergenommen
als Argumente gegen Video im Internet.
Naja.
Ich behielt recht.
Für die Leute damals war aber eine andere
Realität einfach nicht denkbar.
Die Prozessorleistungen, die Datenraten von
heute waren einfach unvorstellbar.
Und so ist es mit so vielem: Künstliche Intelligenz
wird die und die Fähigkeiten haben.
Skeptiker: Niemals.
Warum?
Weil ihre Vorstellungskraft nicht ausreicht.
Oder der Klimawandel: Die Temperatur wird
um mehrere Grad steigen, Inseln werden untergehen.
Nein, so schlimm wird das niemals.
Wie wir heute wissen.
Eine krasse Fehleinschätzung, weil… die
Vorstellungskraft nicht ausreicht.
Oder Oumuamua ist eine Aliensonde oder ein
Teil davon.
Diese Möglichkeit bleibt nach der Einschätzung
des Leiters der Abteilung Astronomie der Harvard-University
Professor Alexander Loeb im Moment als einzige
Erklärung, weil er es im Moment anders nicht
erklären kann.
Was war hier unter den Videos zum Thema los.
Manoman und warum, weil die Vorstellungskraft
dafür nicht ausreicht.
Die Nasa sagt, dass wir so oder so in den
nächsten 20 Jahren Spuren von Aliens finden
werden.
Also warum soll es dann kein Interstellares
Objekt sein?
Wenn die Nasa sagt in den nächsten Jahren
bedeutet das: in den nächsten 7300 Tagen
wird es passieren.
Die Chancen also an jedem tage stehen 1 zu
7299 Das so unglaublich viel höher, als im
Lotto eine Million zu gewinnen und trotzdem
passiert das ständig.
Wenn wir also ein höchst seltsames Objekt
aufspüren, sind die Chancen also mathematisch
extrem hoch, dass das genau dieser Moment
sein könnte und das einzige, was dagegen
spricht, ist…. die mangelnde Vorstellungskraft.
Und jetzt kommt ein weiteres Indiz dazu.
Eine neue Studie unterstützt die These, dass
es sich um ein extrem leichtes Objekt handeln
müsste, dass nur so durch den Strahlungsdruck
der Sonne beschleunigt werden konnte.
Denn wenn das Objekt diese Eigenschaften hat,
dann hat es auch eine weitere sehr bemerkenswerte
Eigenschaft.
Vor Eintritt in unser Sonnensystem hätte
Oumuamua nämlich eine sehr ähnliche Geschwindigkeit
in Betrag und Richtung wie die Plejadensterne.
Der Autor der Studie Thomas Marshal Eubanks
hat sich daraufhin untersucht, wie sich ein
Sonnensegel von den Plejaden zu uns in unser
Sonnensystem bewegen würde.
Wie würden Staub und Gas auf das Sonnensegel
einwirken und seine Flugbahn zu uns beeinflussen
und auch hier wird wieder die These von Abraham
Loeb bestätigt.
Ein Sonnensegel würde sich genauso verhalten.
Alles passt zusammen, wenn es…. ein Sonnensegel
ist.
Bam.
Und er sagt und hier wären wir wieder bei
der Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung, wenn es ein
solches Objekt zu uns geschafft hat, dann
muss es mehr davon geben.
Noch ein Bam.
Sein Vorschlag: Wir wissen jetzt woher diese
Objekte kommen und welche Flugbahn sie haben.
Wir müssen jetzt nur noch in diese Richtung
schauen und müssten solche Objekte mit Monaten
bis zu einem Jahr vor dem Durchflug durch
unser Sonnensystem finden.
Dann wären wir in der Lage eine Sonde zu
dem Objekt zu schicken um es näher zu untersuchen.
Wow!
Das ist wirklich der Hammer.
Demnach wären wir in der Lage wahrscheinlich
schon bald ein solches Objekt zu untersuchen.
Es bleibt spannend!
Wie finden wir Aliens?
Draufklicken, anschauen und Neugierzone abonnieren!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!